[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jona
pareigis willkommen an diesem
sonntagabend den sport hat noch mit
lehmann für sich sondern blicken wir auf
die großen themen heute
bei einem russischen raketenangriff in
der ukraine starben viele menschen nur
kilometer von der polnischen grenze
entfernt
die krone incidents erreicht einen neuen
höchstwert lockerungen stehen deshalb in
der kritik
und die paralympics in china sind zu
ende wettkämpfe geprägt vom krieg sorgen
und diskussionen über menschenrechte
zum einen laufen verhandlungen zwischen
der ukraine und russland und dabei gebe
es sogar fortschritte sagen beide seiten
zum anderen aber wird weiter gekämpft
bei einem russischen raketenangriff auf
eine militärbasis wurden jetzt
mindestens 35 menschen getötet und
134 verletzt der truppenübungsplatz ja
wo reef liegt im westen des landes in
der nähe von lemberg nur wenige
kilometer von der polnischen grenze
entfernt
thomas consumer und christoph distel
berichten
krieg wo bisher krieg nur geübt wurde ja
wo rief nach der luftattacke vor ein
paar monaten arbeiteten hier noch
nato-ausbilder moskau sagt nun der
beschuss galt westlichen söldnern und
waffen die gegend unweit von polen
schien bisher sicher nie war der ukraine
krieg so nah am westen auch zivilisten
werden beschossen weiterhin jenny hilf
die 300.000 einwohner stadt eingekesselt
und größtenteils zerstört dieser mann
wird gerettet für andere werden
wohnungen zu fallen angst verzweiflung
schlagen um in wut
seit verband klagt eine anwohnerin ihr
angreifer ihr sollt so leiden wie wir
leiden tag und nacht gott schütze uns
vor den attacken fliehen das geht nur
auf eigene faust denn fluchtrouten so
heißt es konnten mit russland nicht
vereinbart werden auch ein geplanter
korridor kommt wieder nicht zustande der
nach mario pohl und zurück was von der
metropole übrigblieb sollen diese bilder
zeigen mehr als 2100 menschen sagt der
bürgermeister wurden insgesamt getötet
nun ein versorgungs track aufgehalten
eine anschließende evakuierung
verhinderten sogar orthodoxe priester
die lieferungen mit essen wasser und
medizin begleitend sagte der präsident
russland wolle städte mürbe machen
einnehmen und wie in metropolen und
person marionetten verwaltungen
installieren interessen protestieren sie
dagegen unbewaffnet während warnschüsse
fallen
und sie rufen razón ist ukrainisch
im ukrainischen odessa ist für uns
katrin eigendorf kathrin jetzt also
einen russische raketenangriff auf einen
ukrainischen militärstützpunkt nahe der
polnischen grenze wies das einzuordnen
vor allem putin hat ja mehrfach schon
gedroht richtungen nato dass er bereit
ist ziele ganz im westen der ukraine
anzugreifen wo die nato
militärisches gerät und auch personal
auf die andere seite also in die ukraine
transportiert diese drohung hat er jetzt
wahr gemacht und damit in diesem krieg
noch mal deutlich eskaliert der krieg
ist damit ganz ganz nah an eine nato
außengrenze gerückt und das hat er wohl
auch bewusst getan auf ukrainischer
seite hat das dazu geführt dass der
verteidigungsminister noch mal ganz klar
daran appelliert hat an die nato und
auch an alle westlichen partner den
luftraum über der ukraine zu schließen
damit dieser krieg nicht noch weiter
eskaliert danke für diese einschätzungen
kathrin ein dorf in der ukraine
und wie schwierig es ist die menschen im
kriegsgebiet mit dem nötigsten zu
versorgen das zeigt die reportage des
freien journalisten arndt ginzel
der in der ukraine mit einem gepanzerten
medikamententransport unterwegs war
wir fahren vom nordwesten der ukraine
quer durch ein land im krieg wir wollen
richtung süden zehn stunden dauert die
fahrt vorbei an zahlreichen checkpoints
heute sind wir unterwegs mit einem
gepanzerten fahrzeug man sieht die
scheiben sind zentimeter dick ist auch
dringend nötig wir fragen direkt an ihr
vorbei richtung usa vitali und atem
haben uns mitgenommen normalerweise
arbeiten die beiden in der
sicherheitsbranche jetzt sind sie als
freiwillige helfer unterwegs
wir versuchen hauptsächlich menschen aus
kiew weg zu bringen gerade holen wir
medikamente in odessa ab wir kennen uns
in der gegend sehr gut aus wir wissen
wie wir fahren müssen um nicht unter
beschuss zu geraten
wir erreichen odessa am schwarzen meer
im militärischen sperrgebiet treffen wir
daniels alem in der ukraine ist er ein
bekannter fernsehmoderator jetzt trägt
der uniform hat sich freiwillig gemeldet
wir arbeiten mit der armee zusammen und
sind auf der suche nach saboteuren die
sich hier versteckt haben viele haben
wir schon gefunden und hoffentlich
finden wir noch mehr damit wir unsere
stadt vom feind befreien können
die millionenstadt bereitet sich auf
einen möglichen angriff russlands vor
mit panzern und barrikaden schotten sie
sich ab schützen ihre gebäude und ihre
denkmäler und
wenn sie den geflüchteten und den
menschen in der ukraine helfen und
spenden wollen dann können sie das beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine alle
infos auch unter spenden punkt zdf.de
oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
in mehreren deutschen städten sind heute
wieder menschen auf die straße gegangen
um gegen den krieg in der ukraine zu
protestieren zur kundgebung nach berlin
kam etwa 60.000 menschen die
veranstaltung stand unter dem motto
stoppt den krieg frieden und solidarität
für die menschen in der ukraine
viele demonstrierende drogen selbst
beschriebene transparente in blau und
gelb
kommen wir zu corona in einer woche
sollen die meisten maßnahmen in
deutschland fallen und dabei hat die
inzidenz heute einen neuen höchstwert
erreicht dem robert koch institut wurden
146 1607 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden
29 1718 mehr als vor einer woche die
sieben tage incidents liegt erstmals
über
1500 nicole diekmann berichtet heute
mittag in berlin der
bundesgesundheitsminister stellt sein
buch vor titel bevor es zu spät ist auch
das thema pandemien behandelt er darin
und die frage warum politik
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse nicht
immer umsetzt das tue sie jetzt so der
minister mit der änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
er wehrt sich gegen immer lautere kritik
wir schaffen hier neues
infektionsschutzgesetz mit dem man bei
steigenden fallzahlen und einer
bedrohten versorgung in den
krankenhäusern
sofort reagieren kann und mit aus
entsprechenden schutzmaßnahmen die
partie wieder in den griff bekommen kann
keine masken mehr beim einkaufen keine
masken mehr in der schule spitzt sich
die lage zu sein die länder künftig
verantwortlich sein für die verschärfung
von maßnahmen dort aber regt sich
widerspruch die art und weise wie die
ampel jetzt aussteigt ist schlicht und
einfach falsch die länder sind auch gar
nicht beteiligt worden eine mpk macht zu
dem thema auch wenig sind wir brauchen
eine echte notbremse wir brauchen echte
konzepte auch verschärfungen am
arbeitsplatz soll nach plänen des
arbeitsministers zurückgenommen werden
zum beispiel die home office pflicht
protest von den gewerkschaften
infektionsschutz dürfe nicht zur
privatsache werden tests müssen weiter
bezahlt werden arbeits und
gesundheitsschutz am arbeitsplatz weiter
gewährt sein und dieses gute instrument
home office was auch eine menge
infektion vermieden hat in der
vergangenheit muss auch künftig genutzt
werden die ampel aber hält an ihren
plänen fest am freitag soll das gesetz
verabschiedet werden haben mit dem sport
norbert die paralympischen winterspiele
in peking sind jetzt vorbei mit einer
durchaus positiven bilanz aus deutscher
sicht 19 medaillen davon vier mal gold
und platz sieben im medaillenspiegel das
hat die erwartungen deutlich übertroffen
ein stolzes team.de heute bei der
abschlussfeier
das paralympische feuer in peking
erloschen den ukraine krieg erwähnte er
präsident ist pc bei der schlussfeier
indirekt im angesicht der zwietracht
habt ihr die kraft der vielfalt vor
augen geführt als leuchttürme der
hoffnung und champions des friedens die
formulierung champions des friedens in
chinas staatsmedien zensiert der
gastgeber erstmals erfolgreichste nation
bei winter paralympics vor der ukraine
das junge deutsche team mit weniger
goldmedaillen als vor vier jahren aber
durch die erfolge gerade der teenagerin
katzmaier und leonie walter mit guten
perspektiven für die paralympics 2026 in
mailand und cortina
silber für die deutschen skiflieger bei
der wm im norwegischen vikersund im team
wettbewerb sicherte schlussspringer karl
geiger mit einer weite von
238 meter den zweiten platz für das
deutsche quartett hinter den slowenen
und vor den norwegern der einzige
deutsche erfolg bei diesen
weltmeisterschaft
im ersten der vier sonntagsspiele in der
fußball bundesliga feierte erste fc köln
einen 1 0 sieg in leverkusen durch den
treffer von kingsley schindler in der 67
minute die bayer-elf bleibt trotz der
niederlage tabellendritter köln klettert
auf rang sieben hertha bsc trennt sich
von trainer tayfun korkut nach der 0
2-pleite gestern abend im gladbach
reagiert die vereinsführung und
beurlaubt ihren coach nach fünf
niederlagen in folge und dem absturz auf
den vorletzten tabellenplatz ein
nachfolger für den glücklosen corp das
geht noch nicht fest
das wars vom sport dankeschön hat und
wir schauen jetzt noch wie das wetter
wird im nordosten und südwesten viel
sonne sonst durchzug dichter wolken mit
etwas regen höchstwerte 8 bis 16 grad
das heute journal gibt es um 21 45 mit
christian sieh was das ganze team und
ich wünschen ihnen noch einen guten
abend